the Joe Rogan experience you know who
gives me stress when I look at his
schedule Russell Peters yeah he's mean
like she's all over the [ __ ] point a
crate goes to Africa for like six weeks
like he's all you hear Michael Bisping
almost got [ __ ] robbed in Africa mmm
did he really die he's doing a movie the
[ __ ] was you know in Africa doing a
movie and it was 19 I don't know what it
was
he's doing a movie he got a little
liquored up his cab dropped him off and
said your your hotels over there he get
out of the cab he's like where the
[ __ ] my hotel the cab driver drives
off he's like looking around for the
hotel is he said like ten dudes just
started rolling up on him saying I want
your wallet you know if you want to live
you give me your wallet yeah
is this south after this office is like
Singh Donna Lisa Pretoria [ __ ] yeah so
he ran and he got away off so yeah he
got away
yeah he's a big fella you know how to
fight and they probably could sense that
a little bit but if there's ten of them
they usually don't probably hammer too
what is ten Francis in Ghana then you're
giving your wallet just the homies
around if there's one Francis in Ghana
do nothing yeah Eddie Izzard was telling
me that when he was running he ran like
27 marathons in South Africa and when he
went through certain sections of South
Africa they go stop you are not running
through this area we're gonna put you in
a car we're gonna drive you to where
it's safe and then you're gonna continue
your run get this but you will get
robbed like it's like there's areas
where you just will get robbed